people aren't particularly awake to that
fact
we're probably three years away maybe
even less than
from building a computer that has the
capacity to make as many calculations as
reasonable estimates of the calculating
capacity of the human brain are are
currently set at
so that's like say six years and
and we've got something that's eight
times as smart as a human being
god only knows what we're coming up with
here
you hear babies have no theory of mind
it's like
ah yeah
no
they can imitate that's pretty bloody
amazing man like you haven't seen robots
that can do that yet although there are
robots now that you can teach by moving
their their arms you move their arms and
then they'll do it and so you can
actually program them by moving them and
then they'll just repeat it and so
they're getting damn close to imitation
they're really getting close and then
look the hell out man because they're
going to be imitating each other as well
as us and they're going to do it so fast
you just won't be able to believe it
that's coming you know the guys that are
building the autonomous cars like they
don't think they're building autonomous
cars
they know perfectly well what they're
doing they're building fleets of
mutually intercommunicating autonomous
robots
and each of them will be able to teach
the other because their nervous system
will be the same and when there's 10
million of them when one of them learns
something all 10 million of them will
learn it at the same time so they're not
going to have to be very bright before
they're very very very smart because us
you know we'll learn something you have
to imitate it's like god that's hard or
i have to explain it to you and you have
to understand it and then you have to
act it out we're not connected
wirelessly with the same platform but
robots they are and so once those things
get a little bit smart they're not going
to stop at a little bit smart for very
long they're going to be unbelievably
smart
like overnight so
and they're imitating the hell out of us
right now too because we're teaching
them how to understand us every second
of every day the net is learning what
we're like it's watching us it's
communicating with us it's imitating us
and it's going to know it already knows
in some ways more about us that we know
about ourselves you know there's lots of
reports already of people getting
pregnancy
or ch ads for infants
sometimes before they know they're
pregnant but often before they've told
their families and the way that that
happens is the net is watching what
they're looking at and inferring with
its artificial intelligence these uh
artificial intelligence
people that are making these boston
dynamic robots and
you know the the scariest one that i
read about was a darpa one called the
eater robot e-a-t-r um it operates on it
uses as a fuel it uses biological
material as fuel
which means if you're kidding you're
kidding no i'm not kidding e-a-c-r so
this is going to be able to eat dead
bodies in the
field theoretically and use it as fuel
oh good good oh good that sounds like a
fine thing to develop it's a crazy
thought i was just reading one of ray
kurzweil's books i think it was called
how to make a mind i really liked it
actually
um it helped me understand how the brain
compresses information because the
world's really complicated so you have
to make a low resolution representation
of it to live in it and he actually
explained to me in a way that i hadn't
really understood how the brain might do
that neurologically so that was cool but
you know kurzweil is this guy who thinks
that he's a smart guy
and he's the guy that thinks that we're
heading towards the singularity and so
the singularity is you know how
processing speed doubles every 18 months
and like hard disk capacity every year
and
there's a bunch of doublings going on a
huge number of them and
they accelerate exponentially we're
probably three years away maybe even
less
than
from building a computer that has the
capacity to make as many calculations as
reasonable estimates of the calculating
capacity of the human brain are are
currently set at
18 months away
two years away something like that
and then we're 18 months away from
having one that's twice that fast and
then 18 months away from having one
that's twice as fast as that so that's
like say six years and
and we've got something that's eight
times as smart as a human being but
there's a twist on that and this is
kurzweil's twist which is as soon as you
make a machine smart enough to make the
next machine because computers are so
fast that that will scale up to near
infinite community computing power
almost instantaneously there's reasons
to to not think that that will happen
but
kurzweil's traced to back the doubling
of computing power way before the
existence of the transistor and it's
been ridiculously stable crazily stable
so
god only knows what we're coming up with
here
you know and you don't know what
something of infinite computing power
might be like
like you seriously don't know
and there are serious people who are
very very very worried about that it's
sort of like making really fast robots
that can shoot people it's not that
smart and we're doing that too very
rapidly you know how you look you watch
the terminator movies and you see the
robots that miss when they shoot at you
like they're not very bright
because the bright ones not only shoot
at where you are but they estimate where
you're going to be when you make your
escape moves and they shoot there
simultaneously and their death rate is
100
and so
there's no war against the robots i mean
when those things get going they're
going to be so much faster than us that
we'll look like we're moving through
molasses to them what kind of super
intelligence we're going to bring into
being
and i would suggest that we try to bring
one in that's good and moral rather than
one that's evil and demonic
right
so
what can we do about that there's only
one answer to that as far as i know that
works is get your act together
you're going to be the person who's
working in ai right
i know some of these people
they better be good people
because they're going to build whatever
they're like into their machines
they better have their head screwed on
straight
because they're going to get amplified
like math and i don't like what's
happening with google and and facebook
and youtube they're building censorship
bots predicated on a certain kind of
ideology the kind of ideology that we
outlined today
it's a very bad idea
hopefully good people will stop that and
the way you do that is first by stopping
being bad
and everyone can do that a little bit
so i hope that's what everyone does
because
the consequences of not doing it are not
going to be pleasant they never are